one bar and restaurant in Washington DC
has long been known for whiskey the Jack
Rose dining saloon has been home to one
of the world's largest collections of
whiskey bottles dating from Prohibition
and even decades before but in these
difficult days what's been a defining
feature of the bar has become a luxury
and now it's being tapped to keep the
bar and its employees going christina
Ruffini has the story in the quiet of
his empty restaurant bill Thomas is
taking stock
are there any bottles that were on the
walls that you are not quite ready to
sell yet there was a few hundred that we
scrolled away his bar Jack Rose has the
largest whiskey library in the Western
Hemisphere
at least it did until last week when he
started selling it on 13r it sounds like
this collection means a lot to you did
you ever think about just holding on to
it and closing your doors that was never
an option you you can't leave an asset
like this on the wall when people need
help help came by the dram after
coronavirus shuttered the city's dine in
restaurants Thomas started doing take
out and liquidating 2700 prized bottles
to help support his staff eager whiskey
fans social distanced down the block
what's the most expensive bottle you've
sold so far during the sell-off I mean
generally we showed a lot of bottles at
$1,000 a lot of rare stuff yeah
John Murray nabbed a vintage bottle from
the 1980s pretty cool and thirsty
patrons have already snatched up more
than a thousand others stripping these
once stock shelves it's a win-win
situation if I get to get
rare Bourbons and they get to support
their employees it's the best thing in
the world but even the good stuff isn't
enough to keep everyone on the payroll
Thomas had just opened a second
restaurant down the block he estimates
as many as 35 percent of the city's
restaurants might not be so lucky for
many of the small businesses around the
city they didn't have a hundred year
plan that they could pivot into six
months they didn't just keep selling off
in uncertain times it's always smart to
have liquid assets and to do a little
inventory of the good stuff you've
already got that great bottle that you
were thinking about saving for that
special occasion this is the special
occasion crack it open
drink it share it with whoever you're
sequestered with now's the time this is
the time for CBS this morning Saturday
Christina Ruffini Washington liquid
assets I like that he just gave us
permission to drink in quality by the
way bill says he's got a whiskey
warehouse and the special bottles that
he saved and so he can use that to
restock when they open back up I love it
that's awesome awesome great job great
job Christina Ruffini no you can't help
yeah